ancient Egyptians were noticing in the
cemeteries Oh like grandma's mummified
all of the sudden I think they started
to experiment and figure out how to make
fake mummies today we're talking about
what we know about ancient Egypt
and the Pyramids at Giza I'm pretty sure
slaves built the pyramids sounds about
right I remember that they didn't use
the wheel or something they were just
using like not levers but they were just
like pulling it up by hand or pushing it
Yeah right and they like pulled it on
ropes in a line this is our first common
misconception about how the Pyramids at
Giza were built we actually know that it
was a group of ancient Egyptians who
built the pyramids and not by force but
you're right and that a lot of the
stones were actually moved with manpower
and there was no wheels and a lot of
sledges and everything were used to
transport the stones to build pyramids
so were the ancient Egyptians this was
their job to build these pyramids
basically we think that the Egyptians
did it in service to the king whoever
was building the pyramid at the time
some archeologists like to think that
perhaps it was like almost like a form
of tax like we do today with our
government that these men and
potentially women would go and actually
build the pyramids as like tribute to
the king and to as a form of tax
so archaeologists estimate that it took
about twenty thousand people over 23
years to build the Great Pyramid of
Khufu Wow
just one pyramid just the one yeah was
the King that commissioned these
pyramids or the Pharaoh even alive to
see the final product yeah we think so
Khufu probably began building his
pyramid as soon as he got to the throne
I think the pyramids were built to house
the Pharaohs body after they died their
main purpose was to serve as a tomb for
the dead King he was buried in there all
of his funerary offerings and treasures
were also put inside the pyramid as well
but these pyramids also served as like a
display of the Kings power right you
have this monumental structure out in
the middle of the desert and all the
ancient Egyptians could see it from
miles away and stuff and so it served as
as a type of reminder to the people of
who was in charge and who was King so
when they're building the pyramid is it
just building around one room where the
King would be buried or do they have
other rooms with other things in them is
it like a house or is it more just like
one two inside each pyramid there's a
series of rooms that were used to house
the mummy of the King to hold his
funerals and stuff and these pyramids
almost served as a transformation
machine to like help aid the Pharaoh go
from the world of the living into the
world of the dead because of that is
there any like bad food ooh if you will
involved around like were they not
allowed to see the room before they died
or there's a common thought that ancient
Egypt has a lot of curses and you know
with this Bad Voodoo and everything and
we just don't have a lot of evidence for
it we don't have any inscriptions inside
the pyramids that say you know don't
enter you know or yeah booby traps and
everything yeah
not everybody in ancient Egypt was
mummified it definitely was reserved for
the upper classes or the elites and the
pharaohs and the royal family and there
were even different levels of
mummification that you could have the
more money you had the finer your mummy
could be I took a class like a two week
class but I don't know very much I know
that way because we had to mummify like
an orange uh-huh that was our assignment
so I remember we like put like a bunch
of different spices on the orange and
then just wrapped it in gauze
I don't know if that's actually how it
works but that was middle school okay
yeah
mummification was a process that we
think took maybe 40 days to complete
usually the person would die and then
they would start mummifying their body
right away
oh I remember their scrape their brains
out through their nose uh-huh yeah that
was really great part of mummification
includes removing all of the internal
organs so the brain was taken out
through the nose they'd cut an incision
in your side and they'd remove your your
lungs and your stomach and intestines
and and all this stuff do we know how
they figured out how to mummify but like
where they're a bunch of kings that they
experimented on that I don't know it
didn't work so the earliest mummies that
we have from ancient Egypt are actually
just bodies that were preserved by
accident in the deserts and the desert
sands can actually naturally mummify a
body and dry it out and so we think
through time as ancient Egyptians were
noticing in the cemeteries oh like
grandma's mummified all of the sudden I
think they started to experiment and
figure out how to make fake mummies
so as an Egyptologist part of what I
have to study is the hieroglyphic
language of the ancient Egyptians I can
read and write hieroglyphs doesn't they
have two languages one language that was
reserved for like special documents of
things uh how's that true throughout
Egyptian history what's pretty common is
the nice hieroglyphs so all what we
think of like the nice pictures and
stuff were written on tomb walls on the
walls of temples but then they had a
different kind of script called high
Radek which is almost like cursive
hieroglyphs so it's like a shorthand of
the nice pictures and stuff and those
were for more like administrative
documents love poetry letters between
people so yes in a way there there's a
more formal writing and a more informal
writing of the language good there's a
lot that goes into making the pyramids
you know and a lot that we still don't
know yeah which is interesting well this
was so great and I'm really glad I got
to sit down with you guys and chat about
the pyramids
[Music]
[Music]